i want to let you guys know that next
week i'll be touring there doing florida
hollywood florida june 23rd fort myers
june 24th daytona beach
june 25th in lakeland florida june 26th
tickets on sale now at theovonn.com
tour and thank you guys for your support
today's it's hot as hey it's hot as heck
in here
i don't know why
it is just
it's hot outside
and um
the acs are something
you know coils or whatever
um
yeah i mean it's like somebody just damn
put a bunch of heat in here
like somebody just damn back the damn
truck of sunlight up into this [ __ ]
today's guest uh
fortunately he rolls with the punches
because
hey boy
because we in here um
i'm i'm grateful to have him he has uh
hit singles in country music he's a
music man
and he has hit singles uh pretty hard
and to be loved by you
uh i think if you if you like if you
like this podcast i believe you'll like
some of his tunes um
yeah i'm grateful that he's here uh he
was just voted best new uh male country
male
and that's
i mean that's you know
that's unbelievable
so um
he is extremely talented he's out of
texas
uh
and um
yeah i don't know why i'm rambling but
uh
i i think i i need i i needed him to be
here today and so i'm very grateful uh
enjoy the episode with mr parker
mccollum
[Music]
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Music]
[Applause]
it's time to sweat
i know dude it's time to sweat
it's sweaty in here today it is sweaty
do you feel like it's sweaty in here not
yet i don't really sweat a whole lot
really yeah
oh dang do you think you might have uh
because i guess you're from kind of a
desert area is that right no not at all
oh really from like the sprawling
metropolis of north houston
oh really yeah man i mean i grew up you
know out in the country but very very
close to
a lot of [ __ ]
okay very humid very hot is it i think
i'm just immune to it dang yeah you
might be man built up an immunity um
because you grew up out in uh i know
you're in texas and is that west texas
considered no no i grew up in southeast
texas just north of houston um and then
i lived in austin ten days after i
graduated high school i moved to austin
and
i was like i'm gonna be a [ __ ]
country singer really yeah
sorry nerd i got in late last night
that's good though do you have a good
time
no man i did not i had a i think well i
mean
i don't know if i did or not
parker mccallum ladies and gentlemen
uh thanks for being here man man thanks
for having me i appreciate it yeah it's
nice to get to meet you um
yeah i had i had my i we had to go do an
intervention on a family member
yesterday so it was like damn you know
have you you know shane gillis is yeah
yeah have you seen his live in austin
stand up
um is that his special yeah where he
talks about taking his sister that was
doing heroin and her intervention they
took her to six flags i haven't seen
that part uh-oh it's rich
gold dude then that's what we should
have done yeah because we took her yeah
we just wanted one flag it was like the
flag of surrender and cheated and you
know and um
and we didn't see it
so it was just a long day man you had a
better day than me you played nissan
stadium yesterday i did yeah last night
that was good crazy man yeah it was good
dude it was uh
my mom was there so i think that's kind
of cool you know we're not
so
she probably didn't i probably didn't
look like the most promising prospect 10
years ago to play country music
successfully so i think that's
probably helps her sleep a little bit at
night to see it going well like that oh
really do you think that so 10 years ago
you think she didn't have probably as
much confidence in you no i mean i just
i don't think i was you know if you'd
look at it from like a scout evaluating
a ball okay you say all right
he's never gonna make it
you know and then he makes it to the
league so
um did it feel like that last night
coming out there like with that i'm
making it to the league i mean that must
have felt like something unique i mean
not many people get to play a stadium uh
no matter how well they're doing man it
was cool i was so tired
and so hungry um
that i was really excited to get done
with it and go home yeah but it was dope
certainly a lot of people
when was it the kind of the thing where
i am swa am i on dang drugs yeah but
it's kind of shiny and it looks good
it's bouncing yeah that's good
come get it yeah if there's anybody out
there with dry skin cold spice
commercial coming in
come give me a hug honey i will
definitely moisten you up um
yeah did it feel like so you're walking
out in front of that many people
uh can you feel does your body start to
not because i mean i have feelings i'll
walk out in front of a few thousand and
there's moments where like i think
especially the first time where it's
like
okay are my legs still moving forward
like it's almost you disconnect a little
bit from yourself man that that's only
happened to me one time when we played
the houston rodeo at the beginning of
this year it's like the only time that i
was like gummy worm legs out there
you know i'd had like i tried to have a
couple cocktails take the edge off 71
000 people sold out the houston texans
stadium we were headlining
and the stage is rotating and i was the
whole like 60-minute show i'm out there
and i was just
it was just like a mess dude like i ate
[ __ ] on stage i've never fallen on stage
really i fell
it was great oh it was just yeah it was
the full the full experience
and when you were saying do you feel
like as you were singing that you also
like had control over what you were
saying because i would i'm trying to
wonder if because physically i could
understand maybe it's like oh man it's
overwhelming right it's like usually if
i'm nervous like one or two songs in
you're back to it's probably the same
thing with doing stand-up like you know
even if you are nervous like once you
get into your jokes you're rolling right
you've done it a thousand times but that
was like the one night that i was like
the whole entire show i was just like
googly-eyed up there i could not gather
myself wow yeah so last night when i
walked out there i was just
i just i don't know you're kind of just
normal you've done it yeah yeah
dang it isn't it kind of interesting how
things that would seem like a dream
start to feel kind of normal
yeah well that that like kind of messes
with me with crowds man when we go
somewhere we'll only sell like three or
four thousand tickets which is a lot of
people it's a lot it used to be like
huge for us and now when we only saw
three or four thousand i'm like
we peaked right over and the next night
we'll sell ten thousand but it's like
it's that perspective thing man you get
it's crazy what you can get used to yeah
very quickly yeah yeah how quick it
happens yeah that's really what's wild
um
so you started i know you started out
over there in texas man and uh tell me a
little bit about like do you remember
like the first like song or anything you
ever heard do you remember anything like
that yeah the first like song i ever
fell in love with was amarillo by
morning by george
yeah which was a good one yeah yeah i
didn't even know what amarillo was man
and i remember i just played there on
saturday night wow yeah i called it
their national anthem on stage and i got
a real good reaction they liked that a
lot
um
yeah i remember hearing
i'm trying to think of the first oh i
heard bon jovi was the first song that i
ever heard they're gonna be a big deal
yeah yeah the first time i remember
hearing a song bon jovi and i was with
like a babysitter i've told the story
before but i was with a babysitter and
so i think like there was also like a
woman there my mom wasn't there was she
hot yeah uh i mean she was yeah i feel
like all babysitters are hot when you're
the baby they're sitting dude yeah you
know oh i was like dang yeah i wanted
her clothes kendra scott actually used
to be my babysitter really kid yeah true
story she's dave scott who is it bring
her bring her up trevin she was the she
was dating my uncle back in the day
kendra scott she's like the big jewelry
maker
all the girls wear all her stuff let's
get an image of her and that used to be
her babysitter huh yeah she watched me
when i was a little kid
and now she's like a billionaire oh she
is dang she's done very well
and uh do you have any recollections of
the babysitting going on no dude i don't
remember it at all i would not have
known had my mom not told me she's like
oh yeah she used to date your uncle and
she used to watch you guys dang and your
uncle must have really he what happened
with him he couldn't he couldn't hang on
huh dude i think
i don't know i've never really heard the
full story but he uh it's my uncle chris
my dad's little brother and he was just
like a future hall of famer in the game
of life
was he true og oh is he and it does not
surprise me that he was pulling that
back in the day wow
he's been he's a real aficionado when it
comes to the gals there is no question
damn yes
i think i said i didn't get that part of
that that gene in the family you didn't
no i don't think so dude i'm sure you i
mean you can't feel like you kind of
look like i mean you look like you play
like you would play center on like uh
on justin bieber's like fan on fantasy
basketball team i feel like i feel like
if he had a fan league basketball team
you'd play center i think you're you
seem like you're doing fine i would love
to play center on justin bieber's family
basketball team and may have missed my
calling
um
but you're locked down i know you
recently got engaged you recently got
married yeah yeah i got married i'm like
two months in was it uh
and what does that feel like does it
feel different being married does it
feel
no i've been home like three nights
since we got married
so
it's uh is no different
at all dang other than now when i come
off stage i just get on my bus and go to
bed yeah so that's about the only thing
that's changed yeah so take me out of
them so take me where you start music
you start the first song you hear or
that you remember hearing is george
strait amarillo by morning that's the
first song you remember hearing yeah the
first one i can remember being like
i like that that sounds good
i want to do that
and i was probably like
i don't know seven
maybe six years old something like that
but my older brother tyler he's like
phenomenal songwriter he was the one
that when i was a kid
you know he's big brother i just wanted
to do whatever like he could have been
[ __ ] ice skating and i would probably
be professional ice skater right now
like whatever big brother was doing is
what i wanted to do but he happened to
play guitar and want to write songs and
i was like all right i'm going to do
that
so that's do you have no doubt that
that's kind of where you're where your
passion for it came from no question no
and i just i don't know i remember being
like a little kid and i would
hear that song or any song and i would
sing it and all the time but i don't
think anybody ever thought that i would
sing it for
or be singing 20 years later
so
and at what point did it start to turn
into kind of a job for you because or
even like a like how did it evolve then
into a hobby did somebody get into an
instrument did you like were you like
dialed in at school and music no i was
like sweating so bad dude i think it's
good for a
i was just i just went for a run so the
lights look so good on the sweat dude i
would just own it
i'm opening it but i just i think it's
sharp dude i think it's kind of set in
the vibe
there's no question with the time of
year that we did this interview yeah
there's no doubt about that yeah it's
[ __ ] summertime the good thing is
summer's almost over though so not a
whole lot of heat left you know only
about four months well at least two
months of her sitting right over here on
my forehead that's for sure baby dang i
feel lit up man it's wet i feel like the
lord is just
god washing me with his tongue
um
so i'm try dude i am so sleeky i can't
even like i feel like get my thoughts
together at all dude that's good man
that's what i feel like you're making me
feel better i was debating hitting the
pen before i came were you really yeah
yeah damn but it's kind of hit or miss
yeah because sometimes you hit the pin
and like you're real funny and you're
witty and and it goes well and other
times you hit the pen and you're like
i mean just as worthless as could ever
be yeah i was like man i think i'll just
no pen this morning yeah i think that's
probably a good choice i mean it's yeah
i think that's that risk because you
can't tell exactly how much you're gonna
get yes you know and this my driver
shout out flex always gives me these
pins he always like sneaks them you know
when i'm getting out i'll like give him
a hundred dollar bill and he's a little
he's like the cr the pins nowadays look
like they come from target anything in
the candy section yeah and they'll hand
me one and sometimes they're
i mean it's like you know doing crack or
something i mean you hit it and you're
like i don't dick what is weed nowadays
man back when i was in high school like
it was dirty and had seeds and stems you
know and nowadays it's like like you may
end up literally like dead it's so
powerful oh i feel yeah some of the
stuff man i remember hitting something
one time and i felt like they were just
like somebody had done construction in
my head yeah you know does it make you
think a lot
hmm
well that's a good word like it made me
think i didn't want to hit it because i
would come in here and i would look you
dead in the eye
and you'll be talking yeah and then i'll
you get done talking i don't have to go
theo what did you just say because i'm
out there thinking about the fact that
we're on a rock floating around a ball
of fire in the void you know instead of
having the conversation that i'm a part
of and so i was like
we'll just we'll hit it after we don't
know where we go on the way home i feel
like it gives my mind a vacation
sometimes if when i used to smoke it
would get my mind a vacation but somehow
i'd get too paranoid and then one of the
first times i ever got high was at this
girl's house and everybody had left we
all smoked weed and everybody else left
the room and then uh
i remember her dead i kind of like
her dad had been like sitting there
watching me be stoned like i was just
like laying on the couch being stoned
and it scared me so bad i thought i had
been in this room for like 15 minutes by
myself i was like talking out loud and
kind of like
saying positive things to myself and
[ __ ] and then i look over
and her dad who is one of our teachers
at our school was [ __ ] standing there
dude oh no
and man i think at that point it made me
feel so in like kind of introverted
about
when i was stoned you know
and then i used to get um when i was
young me and my buddy would uh we ate a
bunch of no-does one time we were
supposed to go pick these girls up nodos
yeah it was like caffeine pills you know
and this before we could get any weed
you know this is like we're just like
what can we do at the convenience store
to make us feel different than we do
right now yeah 100 baby
so
uh
yeah i took we took a pack man and um or
we took we split a pack or something we
were supposed to pick these girls up for
this date and we parked like by the
street and
we were so hot we just
i don't know we could feel our hair
growing and [ __ ] and
and we literally we couldn't we couldn't
move and get out of the vehicle so we
just looked over at these
we could see them on the porch waiting
for us and [ __ ] and
and we just sat we just just sat in that
car for a long time
it's it's uh
like it's a hit or miss thing man
sometimes i hit it and i'm like
you know i've written some of some of my
biggest songs
yeah some of the biggest songs i've ever
written
or right after coming off of them yeah
oh no it just makes me we think weird
and then
but it's so funny like
i hit that pin all the time way too much
and
every single time i take a rip of it for
20 minutes i'm like i need to get my
life together i'm a failure this isn't
going well and then after 20 minutes i'm
like
damn i wanna hit that pen again that was
great you know but it's the paranoid
thing you're talking about
it's like every time well it's
interesting though because then why
would our brains be like hey i want to
hit it again yeah well it's because
after the the paranoid goes away you're
like
oh this is great now remember like it's
like wolf of wall street when they take
the quaaludes
yeah you know and like you have to get
through the phase of like where they're
moving like snails like you have to
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah you know that
it's like once they get past that it's
like pure euphoria
yeah that's a good point man it's like a
like a lesser example
of that
i'm trying to think i remember like yeah
i i if i smoked weed like i remember if
i was with a chick i felt like it made
your girlfriend feel like a new
girlfriend
that was one thing that was great about
it dude if you if your girlfriend
doesn't it seems like the same old
girlfriend
and you hit a little bit of weed bro
yeah surprise you i remember one point
sitting there having to guess my
girlfriend's name bro yeah because i
didn't know you know that's a lot a lot
of options too it's hard to get it right
you only got one you know
and you can't ask her i was looking
around the house for clues and [ __ ] yeah
reading old valentine's day you gotta
take them to starbucks right
and let them order a coffee and then
they put their name on the cup and
that's the old trick
that's a great idea if you wake up you
don't know who she is you take them to
starbucks praise god baby that [ __ ]
vintay for vanessa yeah
oh is that what it is that's it dude
that's classic man i never tried that
that's a great trick man
we had a question come up with uh well
i'm just
this this today's just been a [ __ ]
day bro uh i'm glad to be a small part
of it yeah yeah dude thanks for coming
man i appreciate it i'm sorry you catch
me on such a weird time i almost
i was like should i even cancel
yesterday i didn't want to cancel
because i'm happy that you're here you
know dude i'm like the king of canceling
so hadn't you canceled it i've been like
hell yeah let's do it another day i love
canceling plans i don't think there's
anything there's no better relief you
feel like when you have something yeah
you know like last night had you had a
dinner you had to go through after
everything
that you went through yesterday if you
had something you had to go to
you would have been there the point
comes like an hour before
we're like dude
i don't want to go actually stay home
yeah and like the greatest relief in the
world
is when you make up your mind that you
don't give a [ __ ] you're canceling oh
yeah like after that then you're just
like oh we're not going oh you know but
it's like that when you're stressing
about having to go
and you decide to cancel it's like it's
better than any drug in the world dude
damn that is interesting that is a real
high canceling no question because
especially if you have a good excuse
especially if you do yeah i had a great
one yeah
i was like dude i've been in a
yeah i've been in an intervention i
would say that yeah that's a gravy one
usually i'm like hey i'm tired
yeah you know and you just sound like a
[ __ ] like it's not
yeah i never have a soul was tired we're
in there like pleading you know and they
said it was like three hours
and it was um
it was good but it just and then when
you come up with the l and an
intervention you're like damn you want
to get the squad together how do we
regroup who do we send in next time
should we have done matching outfits
like how do we get this right you know
do we need a baritone like what do we
need
to pull off the solid intervention and
then had you had a dinner last night and
you'd been able to cancel or cancel this
podcast today you've been like [ __ ] yeah
i'm chilling i got the whole day to just
screw off now which are the others those
are the best days that's my weed pin
dude
yeah dude it's a it's a hidden gem among
people who are very busy bro that's a
great you should do like sometimes one
of your buddies is flipping out about
something you have to do take his phone
and be like hey i'm not coming we're not
[ __ ] going yeah dude i i look forward
to it all the time and then you know
like it's it's a blessing and a curse
right it's good to be busy yeah it means
you got some [ __ ] going on some people
are expecting you to be somewhere it's a
good thing right
but sometimes i'm just like
[ __ ] dude i'm not going yeah i don't
even have an excuse yeah i'm just not
[ __ ] going dang i can't make it
mm-hmm sorry about it oh that's
beautiful sorry about it it's my dad's
birthday
i want to make that a license plate on a
car i'm like a cool corvette yeah make
it my dad's birthday so
just see you always be like why did
what's what does that mean oh it's my
dad's birthday sorry yeah
it's the greatest excuse
dude that is a great excuse man wow
thanks bro yeah now i feel much more
relaxed honestly
yeah because and then the planes got
delayed and i'm like how do i thought
about just driving or just getting a
driver that was just like what are we
even doing and i was in baton rouge so
it was just like
you know just like it was just a lot and
it was just like
family people had been crying it was
just like jesus you know yeah somebody i
thought that was going to get high
because of the intervention i'm like
yeah i'm going to need
i'm going to need to uh what is the drug
of choice in this intervention i don't
know we didn't know what they were on oh
that makes it super that's a way that's
a whole other
ballgame that's like a guessing
intervention it was a lot that's like
yeah it's like if the members of the
game clue
had to have an intervention like mr plum
or something
he'd be like i think she's doing heroin
with a needle in the laboratory you know
i think so
yeah i think she's doing opium with a
curling iron
in the trap house in the trap house yeah
dude you're saving my day today man
thank you bro thank you for making me
laugh man i'm glad dude you uh you may
you have made me
literally cry laughing staring at my
phone oh thanks multiple times so i'm
glad i could turn the favor i appreciate
it yeah man you really are yeah you
really really are man um
you know there's only two medicines that
are fda approved to keep your head well
with hair keep your head warm
i have a friend at night his head gets
all cold and you see him
his wife will put a small blanket on his
head because he don't have any hair
it's heartbreaking to see and a lot of
you have seen it in your families step
families
that's why keeps is here to help keeps
has everything your hair needs delivered
straight to your door with discreet
packaging
and proven results
prevention is key treatments can take
four to six months to see results so act
fast when it comes to your hair save
more and spend less with keeps
if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss
go to keps.com
t-h-e-o to receive your first month of
treatment for free
that's
k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash theo to get your first
month of treatment for free treat your
head well
damn quit living in sin
k-e-e-p-s dot com
slash theo
you know big wireless is causing trouble
again
you've seen it
they're causing trouble you see somebody
phone calls get dropped and
uh they can't um
can't call some certain people family
members that's why mint mobile decided
to shake up the wireless industry with
their brand new modern family plan
no matter how big or small your family
is you deserve to save on your wireless
service
they'll get you done
for anyone who hates their phone bill
mint mobile offers wireless service for
just 15 bucks a month that's right
whether you're buying for one or a
family
and at mint families start at two lines
their modern family plan lets you mix
and match data plans so everyone
gets the amount of data that's right for
them
that's right to get your new wireless
plan for just 15 bucks a month including
the modern family plan go to
mintmobile.com
theo
that's m i n t m o b i l e
dot com slash t h e o cut your wireless
bill to 15 bucks a month at
mintmobile.com
theo
so yeah i i want to know a little bit so
like you kind of have been picked as the
guy like you get these they get these
accolades in the business side of music
right
and you've had a lot of those right like
this is the guy that you know the pick
to click little things that rhyme you
know like click or whatever you know
what i'm saying like the uh
the uh
you know like the
uh
i don't want to say like the key
i'm trying to think of a good one like
you know the next guy to shine you know
what i'm talking about and a lot of them
are great like you know from
i don't know if it was the country music
awards that gave you like the top new
mail artist of the year right
yeah right congratulations thanks man
yeah it's amazing what i'm trying to get
to is
how do you get like is there then some
type of formula is there's and what
pressure comes with how to
fulfill that because really it's kind of
like saying hey bruh here's a bunch of
pressure
yeah no man no is that what it feels
like maybe that's my interpretation not
at all dude uh the awards are cool you
know like i watched the award shows as a
kid
so yeah it's cool to be on them you know
it's just kind of like kind of like the
stadium thing last night you know you're
like
damn i used to sit out there now it's
kind of the same concept which is really
cool but
man and i don't know if it's if it's a
blessing or a curse but i just don't
give a [ __ ]
yeah you know i really don't i just want
to
be as successful doing this
with as much integrity and respect
as i possibly can trying to do i've done
it the hard way you know like started
from the very very very bottom in my
pickup truck got a van got a trailer got
a nicer van got a tour bus then signed a
record deal now we have like three tour
buses 18 wheeler the whole deal
did it the long hard way
how i wanted to do it and so the awards
are great man the the number one song is
great double platinum song awesome
but
it just doesn't like that's not what
makes me feel successful you know it's
uh they're they're like just little
bonuses i guess um but there's no really
pressure i mean
you know whether you win that award or
you don't you still gotta put out
another record and you still gotta go on
the road next weekend you know so it's
they're great but
um i don't know if you're not doing it
if you're not relevant in like twenty
you look like george strait dude he's
like say he just turned 70 and he's
still selling out like us bank stadium
yeah
you know i'm 29 i just played at send
amphitheater in nashville yeah i had a
long [ __ ] way to go dude so the
awards are good but
very hopefully the very very beginning
of the road
and what gets you to that next like is
there a thing is it more
you know because i wonder i i don't know
if it translates with comedy but it's
just like is there some i guess is it a
certain type of song that kind of
like what do you feel like you have to
have then to continue to keep a
a trajectory then or even a
a
continuation of man i think i think it's
the songs and that's what i tell all
like you know the it's weird now that
there's like young guys asking me stuff
because i was always the young guy
asking the stuff and now i got these
younger kids asking me
for advice and stuff and i'm like dude
if you don't have the songs
you're [ __ ] yeah like you may have a
good you may have a big single on
country radio
maybe i mean if you have songs you can
sell tickets and that's how you tour and
have a career right so
that's like the biggest thing man you
got to have you got to have you got to
write and have the best songs like garth
brooks
i mean mega hits george strait mega hits
you look at tim mcgraw any genre and
that you know country music really
probably has the most longevity of any
genre it seems like it looks like rap
and pop music like you don't see a lot
of 50 year olds still killing the game
and popping rap but there's people
getting murdered all the time yeah a lot
a lot of dying a lot you know it's like
yeah it's not like every couple of weeks
uh you know a young tim mcgraw gets
gunned down somewhere no you know dude
he probably you've seen him
have you seen him agrawal lately i just
the bullet would show 1830 too the
bullet would probably bounce off and
dude he's nasty ripped really yeah dude
go look at his instagram
he's like 50. god and would just piece
me up bring him up there let me see that
man
he is a seriously god
i wish i was uh
tim mcgraw's name tim mcgraw dude
uh og also a future hall of famer in the
game of life probably oh this guy
yeah i saw him in 1832.
he's um
there was a good there was a good
picture just but can you just go to his
instagram brother
he's nasty rip though dude like nobody's
gunning him down you know
yeah i feel like they could gun me down
pretty easy really especially if i was
if i'd hit the pin already
probably easy target moving slow when
you if you get off stage here he is
right here dude
yeah but we use it on the road quite a
bit too it's called the bar complex and
all into it and it's a combination of 10
or 12 exercises for the purposes of time
and so many people out of work we do six
and we have two each round we'll do our
i mean he's making a million dollars on
stage that night
and he's out there working out at 11 a.m
oh wow he's doing that look at that
oh look at that i mean what a g dude
and you're going home to faith hill and
you look like that come on dude you
gotta really care i would have mirrors
all over that's good
i'd have just mirrors in my house i'd
get rid of the damn wallpaper yeah
nothing but mirrors i want to look at me
baby oh yeah
i want to look at a little bit of extra
time sit down for dinner dear lord i'd
like to say grace and letting everybody
thank you for me amen
[Laughter]
take the a and the n out of it baby me
me um there's no i and amen but there's
me you
[Laughter]
thank you lord for me yeah
yeah man um
do you have a a a a routine when you're
out there on the road what's that like
for you nah man super lame yeah super
bummer i either wake up and play golf or
i try to go to a gym and work out not
like all timmy over there
um i like to go
i like to go and put a lot of weight on
either side of the bar
and sit there for like 20 minutes on my
phone
and then i'll just take the weight off
and go back to the bus but i play a lot
of golf on the road dude oh really yeah
nate bargatz is a comedian uh who plays
golf he is
phenomenally funny yeah very funny yeah
unbelievably hilarious but
that's kind of the cool thing about
touring is i mean you're in a different
city every day right so you can play a
different golf course every day now some
days
you're playing like these really nice
country clubs that you're not even good
enough to be playing at and then the
next day you'll be like albuquerque new
mexico playing like antler hole yeah
community golf course and it's solid
dirt oh yeah it's a halfway house
there's meetings and stuff going on
there's 12 step meetings on the fairway
yes do you have you played albuquerque
uh yeah we just played there
a couple weeks ago maybe we were in las
cruces or albuquerque something like
that let's discuss it
there's not a lot going on albuquerque
is
unbelievable bruh dude everybody at the
gas station had a parole officer with
them yeah
with them dude it was like it's like the
wild wild west out there dude
yeah like will smith and whoever was in
that movie with him is going to roll up
on that little spider leg deal any
minute
yeah it's almost like if i saw a drug
dealer i would be at least happy to be
seeing a business person yeah yeah a
hustler yeah like oh man glad to meet
somebody with an llc here
it is uh
drugs incorporated bro
i just never been to anything like that
i didn't know what was going on you know
and they were uh and uh i was talking
about this the other day but
they're always like talking about the
aliens and stuff i was just about to say
that it's like the drugs got to be good
out there because they're seeing ufos
we're not seeing anywhere else
and you don't have any video footage of
them it's like all of a sudden everybody
has a camera in their pocket and we're
not seeing any videos of these ufos
because the aliens are the people
they are we may be the aliens
it's not us bro we're passing do you
think only the citizens of albuquerque
we're we're coming to the zoo to visit
you know and it's not i'm not saying
it's the citizens but it's there is
there are
easily aliens or
you know um
bots or what i don't know what they're
called drug bots i don't know what you'd
call them in albuquerque but they are
woven into the fabric of
the heat the species there maybe that's
how they're getting that stuff into the
united states i mean there is uh it's
definitely
some there's fentanyl in the dna over
there they're sucking people up into
that ufo and they're dropping down
kilos of
coke and all kinds of stuff maybe that's
how it rolls out there
i wouldn't there's uh i wouldn't be
surprised if they are um it's like a you
it's like a greyhound station for ufos i
think that's a great i mean i'll tell
you this it's not somewhere it wouldn't
be on the top of the list of places to
retire yeah yeah
you know if someone told me that they
were retiring
and headed to albuquerque to live out
their days i'd be like
are you in prison yeah yeah you know
yeah did you just catch a large sentence
and that's what you mean by julia yeah
this is my federal retirement yeah
because i think uh
yeah dude it just blew my mind because
we went to the gas station there was a
lot going on you know a guy in there is
like promising the lady he's like hold
my cell phone
and let me pump as much gas and i'll
come back and get my cell phone from you
and she's like that's not a deal for us
she's like i have to give your cell
phone back and you get gas but he like
didn't understand the deal and then this
is all just at a gag where i got a pilot
or a loves or something you know and
then there's this other guy walking
around like this like with his arms like
above his head you know like that
and uh
and he had a parole officer with him
and it was just like i've seen the
backstroke and i've seeing the front
stroke but this was just
this guy was like don't don't don't
don't don't yeah
that's all he said bro he was like i
think he worked for peter or something
you know it was good alien drugs oh dude
i'm like this dude is definitely
this guy's
like they they gotta start putting uh
birth control in the heroin i think
that's what they got they may not you
may be on to something there because i
feel like that's getting out of hand
there's a lot of people nowadays yeah
there's a lot going on um i haven't
considered taking it
really no oh
did it ever i always wanted to smoke
crack honestly that's an honest thing
and after seeing wolf of wall street i
did want to did you [ __ ] smoke crack
with me bro lions and you know that
yeah i never wanted a smoke crack until
i saw that video so i saw that movie
man they look man they make it look
great god they do yeah and they're just
super rich and they're dressed really
nice smoking crack i'm like
i know for you know the long game yeah
that's probably not the play yeah but
for the immediate like 24 to 48 hours if
you had 100 million dollars in a nice
suit
like let's say you had like 48 hours to
live i'm smoking crack
when you gonna do it though in the
beginning or at the end of the 48 hours
uh maybe like the last six hours i heard
it last a long time so yeah
you know go go like skydive
and then maybe smoke crack on the way
down
before you land
it'd be so hard you'd have to get in
like a little box or something to be
able to probably light it in there
i do they have to have pens by nowadays
that's true huh crack pen crack pen dude
i got i was at a smoothie place in maui
this dude's like hey you want to do some
dmt right i've never done it
did you do it yeah and and uh it's
incredible
yeah it was crazy well this guy takes me
back to his house with his wife and
there's children running around and then
that is not ideal yeah that was a bit
much sure this is the place to do it
it's not good and they're like sure you
know
and uh they had like this little dish of
macadamia nuts i remember and i love
those and so i took that as like a sign
like i'm you know
you know everything probably going
pretty good
and uh
and i hit it man and it was
yeah
it was definitely i mean i went out
there you know i was like
i remember feeling like i was at like
i kind of went into the speaker at like
a drive through like a like a
like a drive-through food place like a
sonic or something i went into the
speaker and then i [ __ ] worked at a
foot locker i remember
i remember getting it didn't last very
long no it lasted me i don't know maybe
six seven minutes yeah what was your
experience like man um and where were
you i was in austin texas i was living
on ut's west campus university of texas
west camps at the time i was not
enrolled in school not enrolled i was
writing that first record the limestone
kid i put out
and uh
there was actually um this kid from
india
who was a chemist that we had gone to
high school with that was was majoring
in chemistry at uh university of texas
and uh he had like ordered the bark from
like the amazon rainforest or whatever
that whatever chemical that they get for
the dmt yeah
and uh
and
mark came in he made it like in his and
now looking back i'm like
that like our thought my thought process
that day probably should have taken a
little longer
um but my buddy mom was in town and he
was like hey let's go over to this house
and then this he's like he's incredibly
smart this kid that we went to high
school with and he's chemistry major and
he made this [ __ ] in his dorm room
and everybody took a little hit and i
crawled out on the fire escapes like a
monday morning at 8 am and i like saw
myself as a kid
like i saw a little like five-year-old
me running across our front yard and the
house i grew up in
and then all of a sudden it was back and
i felt amazing afterwards like just
complete did you feel that way
afterwards i felt a little spooked out
for all that don't know what dmt is it's
the chemical in your brain that makes
you dream like we talked about smoking
crack dmt is not crack yeah i know just
for the listeners yeah it's like the
opposite of it yeah it's like can't harm
you
i would recommend everybody one time in
their life does that because it's like
is very
i think it's a good thing
yeah it gave me it's not like a hardcore
drug no right yeah yeah you're probably
not going to see somebody like you know
you're not going to get in like a back
alley or no you know there's not going
to be a shooting over dmt
but it's a crazy it was wild dude and
then like a few minutes and you're out
of it and i was and felt totally normal
felt great dude just
like on cloud nine anyway
yeah i think i don't remember well i did
it then later because then i got i was
like i want to do it again
because i thought i could get to the
next level it was like a video game or
something suddenly i'm like oh i want to
beat that level see i've been different
like all that kind of stuff like any
kind of psychedelics or anything i just
like one or two times and i'm out
i think they're my i think that like
that's what those should be like people
who like like i had buddies that would
eat mushrooms like
all the time yeah and i'm like
i don't think those are for that right
you know like
welch's grapefruit snacks
10 15 packs no problem
but mushrooms
probably probably don't want to buy the
box yeah of those you know just a
one-time two-time deal
yeah yeah
that's interesting man yeah i think
everything's kind of like that you know
but yeah i remember that dmt man and
then we went outside and did it and it
was like in a park and then people were
recognizing when we were leaving and i
felt like i could see kind of skeletons
a little
and that wasn't good so i don't think i
want to do that again you know skeletons
do you want to be happy you want to be
positive i want to stay on the joyous
side of things yes um we had a question
that came in about partying and stuff on
the tour can we get to that
yeah i'm sorry so i don't hear jesus i
don't know what happened did we at least
we need to call guinness book of world
records and so we just we just did the
hottest podcast
all time
it's got to be we should go do one in
the sahara desert and really set the
record get rufus to seoul to play mm-hmm
do it in albuquerque
you could do it in albuquerque the [ __ ]
is somebody left the oven on up and out
it's been on for 100 000 years out there
dude yeah
they don't even have like bushes and
stuff it's so hot dude they got people
there yeah they got to do with two
tongues and he'll be he'll be standing
there talking to a dude with no tongues
and you're like this is insane do you
have his tongue or this is damn
serpentry both of those years let's play
that up buddy
theo parker huge fan of both of you guys
absolutely insane to see you doing a
podcast together very very excited for
it uh my question is for parker i'm uh
i'm a texas guy born and raised been a
huge fan of the you know the more texas
style of country music you know and uh
you kind of hear a lot of tall tales a
lot of speculation a lot of crazy
stories about uh
you and co wetzel on these tours doing
crazy stuff doing just all kinds of
shenanigans i'm wondering if we can get
a story or two out of you some crazy
[ __ ] you and co have done that'd be
really really cool to hear coming from a
fan
uh thanks guys gang gang gang baby yeah
co is unbelievable dude co is like uh
he's like a disco ball and a cowboy boot
kind of you know he's really um he's one
of a kind i want to to come on here i
think he's going to at some point a true
future hall of famer in the game of life
that young man
[ __ ] he's parked mcguire dude he
really does it he's great man and it
kind of bugs me sometimes because
you know people overlook how good of a
singer he is
because his show it's all about you know
so hardcore rock and roll such an
entertaining show
and no one ever talks about how just
[ __ ] good of a single like his voice
is incredible he's such a good scene the
first time i ever met him and heard him
sing i'm like
i'm [ __ ] very unique
yeah dude and uh incredibly creative and
if i was a fan i would i would be a huge
fan if i was just a man i would be a
huge fan of his because i would he he is
like he gives those people 110 of
cowetzel oh he's tootin i mean he's
almost
the sweetest guy in the world dude he's
very he's extreme he's so generous yes i
mean he's just east texas boy dude he's
that's how that's how it rolls out there
man a lot of just very well raised uh
but as far as oh man crazy stories um
yeah there's one in particular that
comes to mind
uh man i hadn't thought about this in a
long time
we uh we were playing in waco texas um
and uh
this place called the backyard and we we
used to do this acoustic tour during
christmas time him and i and uh even
before we had bus tour buses like first
year we did it we were just in a van
together
and uh we do like you know six nights
the week before christmas it's acoustic
go play bars you know and it's like the
level of entertainment was just
unbelievably uh underwhelming
because we were just so messed up every
night by the time we got on stage it was
a lot of fun
and uh
the first year we ever did it we played
waco at the backyard and
uh before we even went on stage i mean
we were
floored dude like i mean i don't even
remember being on stage
and uh
after the show he wanted to go
to
uh the titty bar
and i don't know if you've ever been to
the titty bar in waco but it's smaller
than this room uh there's like two
dancers
and uh and i've that's never been my
thing i've never been a fan of the i
never wanted to have to pay to touch you
know what i mean yeah and uh but co
loves them loves them dude and uh he may
be buried in there one in one of those
ones oh he looks like he loves it yeah
he loves good hitter and uh and i have
no disrespect i cast no judgment i i
don't know look if i've got to go into
one to get to where i'm going i don't
mind passing through you know um
but we come off stage he wanted to go
there and and uh and so we
i don't know who drove us to uber or
somebody drove us this this it's the the
worst
it's like hall of fame
not hall of fame yeah you know worst
hall of fame ever titty bad titty bar
yeah really bad scoliosis i know that
yeah and he will so so we go in there
and we have a few shots and
we don't even we didn't even like no
girls dance or anything we're in there
for like 30 seconds and he orders a
drink
the room's very small
and he picks the drink up in a glass and
just slams it against the mirror on the
wall and just shatters [ __ ]
everywhere and i'm like
dude we're literally either going to
jail or we're going to die
like it was it was it was a scary
situation
and he just doesn't give a [ __ ] dude
like he is just like that's his titty
bar
well so they kick us out and we have to
go into the parking lot we don't have a
ride we don't have anywhere to go it's
like 1 30 in the morning in waco
and it's like a tuesday night you know
the first night of that tour
and dude
well dude i'm like i'm sitting there i'm
like [ __ ] up on my phone trying to
find a way to get us out of there
and i look over and he's in the road on
all fours yeah crawling at oncoming
traffic damn boy true [ __ ] story and
i'm like i'm like i'm sitting there i'm
like oh my god he's gonna hit my [ __ ]
car but i'm too [ __ ] up to do anything
yeah so
pamplona yes and so eventually he you
know he gets up off of the road and and
somehow or another somebody came and got
us and took us back to the venue and
there the venue has like this apartment
you stay at
we go in the [ __ ] apartment he starts
kicking holes in the wall and he's like
he's like screaming at me in the face to
kick a hole in the wall i don't want to
kick a hole in the wall and he's like
he's like you're not [ __ ] going to
bed till you kick a hole in the wall so
i have to kick a hole in the wall oh
damn yeah and i get so i get real you
know even more [ __ ] up and i end up
laying on this little air mattress and
in all of my clothes and i wake up at
like 5 30 in the morning coast still
awake and he's yanking my boots off and
he's just going i never let you sleep in
your boots pete i'll never let you sleep
and just yanking my clothes off of me
and i'm like like vietnam i'm like dude
that was like one of the first times him
and i had been on the road together and
i was like
this guy means business
crazy he's one of my best friends in the
world dude i love him i i would take a
bullet for him any day of the week um
he's a hero i mean he is like beloved by
people yeah dude he's what do when you
when you go that hard
and you give that much to yourself to
those people every night yeah you know
you're gonna get that in return
yeah he i mean he definitely i mean like
there's something about him where he
will give uh he'd give everything he had
to give you all the blood out of his
body 100 percent he's a dude he is a
great dude and i and
everything that kind of surrounds him
and his brand and his vibe and
everything i just
i don't even think people understand or
appreciate just how like good naturally
of a [ __ ] he can just
belt yeah like we get [ __ ] up seeing
frank sinatra
and he can just rip it
it's really impressive
yeah he's got a
i mean he yeah he'd give you the blood
right out of his body how much blood is
even in a body i wonder how much blood's
in a body in there having you pull that
up like five or six liters maybe
is it liters damn huh we've gained it
i mean i'll tell you global warming is
not affecting that [ __ ] huh how many
liters are in a gallon see that's the
problem they give you all these charts
approximately 1.2 to 1.5 gallons okay so
that's like you think about a
gallon of water
that's just one and a half of those
that's crazy i think that's all that's
in us huh i would have thought that was
way more i thought like a little half a
baby pool
half of a baby pool of blood
i wonder if that's ever
been a thing if that's ever
has there ever been a baby pool full of
blood i would hope not
a god i hope not
but yeah i mean i don't know if i could
yeah it's definitely we are here we come
about to find out we are on the last leg
of production staff here as they google
baby pool full of blood baby that's
awesome um
so how do you get to that part where you
know uh
you're just learning about music and
then you get to the part where you get
you and co are going out and touring
together
just get me through some of that
timeline man
i put out my first
record the limestone kid in 2015
[Music]
and
um i had a song called meet you in the
middle that was that kind of blew up off
of it and uh
i had a uh twitter message i had like
just gotten a twitter and it was from
this guy named cowetzel and he was like
hey man like your stuff you know let's
haul it it's right sometime or whatever
and i mentioned back i was like yeah you
know what i would love to
and it's like 2014 2015 something
and uh actually ended up meeting this
guy named jake murphy who's one of uh co
and i's greatest friends also a future
hall of famer in the game of life
um one of my favorite humans on earth
and uh he was buddies with co and and he
had started to roll on the road with me
he was tour managing for me at the time
and he was like man you got to meet my
buddy co and i'm like dude i think he
messaged me one time on twitter i think
he's a singer too right and he's like
yeah he's really good and
um so he we the first time we ever hung
out we went fishing uh i think i want to
say it was on like the leon river or
something in stephenville whatever name
of that creek or river was and it was
like us three people in the smallest
john boat that has ever been made
and uh
and we were fishing and the river had
flooded we almost just had a great time
and um started hanging out and um
you know i mean we just kind of ran
around with the same people and i i was
kind of rolling a little bit all at the
time i had a little bit of steam going
in texas and and uh obviously when i met
him i was like dude he's so [ __ ] good
i was like people got to know you know
so
i was trying to kind of you know
whatever i could do for them and they
didn't need my help whatsoever like they
were
they were raw they were there was no
question they were going to be big time
and uh and but me and him just became
really good friends and and uh we were
kind of the only two in our
circle when we started to see a little
bit of success that kind of understood
you know kind of the things that were
going through our minds [ __ ] we were
dealing with and stuff and so that's
really kind of where
i think we became really good friends
was we kind of had each other to be like
yo
you know talk about your [ __ ] yeah yeah
and um
and so i mean it was i don't know
probably a year or two later i was
sitting at my house in austin um working
on that next record and he called me and
he's like hey man i wrote this song
called love
would you want to finish it write the
last verse and and sing it and i was
like yeah do you mind if i kill her
and he's like no that'd be great so i
wrote the last verse of love like right
there i think i was still on the phone
with him i was like what do you think
about this he's like yeah it's great
let's cut it and we went and cut it and
it was a huge song for him
and did a lot for me too i got way too
much credit for that song more than i
deserved certainly um that whole that he
he really deserves all the credit for
that i just killed her in a little small
verse at the end
and uh man it was like the second that
song came out it was like all right get
ready to be a rock star because i mean
there was no question in my mind he was
gonna be a superstar so
i love him dude he's gonna i would i'd
take a bullet for him any day of the
week people love him because i get a lot
of requests a lot of people ask me about
him just spending time with him i got to
go to the super bowl with him
and uh
dude we had such a good time yeah i mean
he's just so much
he's just so much fun yeah and he's just
so dang lovable yeah you know he's such
a good dude man i mean yeah
i think people see him and
and you know the way he looks and the
way he acts on stage and stuff and and
they probably think that's like
you know like he wakes up in the morning
and it's just like
that away but i mean he's really just a
good dude man he's got a huge heart and
i mean just a good person i love his
family he comes from good people he's a
lot of heart i bet he has more than five
leaders in him the hundred percent way
more than a baby pool good hole i think
he got the hell yeah i think he's a six
liter man i think he has a
album cover or something a baby pool
knowing i think about it i think he is a
damn six liter man bro yeah he could
maybe that's a new nickname for co six
liter man yeah dude because he's got
yeah you need to have him on that dude i
mean he i know i just want to have him
on just from the pure stories
um
and i've also been i mean i just went
through texas touring yeah so it kind of
was like you know
um and i i was we talked about you on
the uh on jelly roll was in here a few
months ago talking about you and i don't
know if that part made it in the episode
because there was some lighting issue
but um
we were both singing a lot of your songs
and stuff and
um and then when i was going through
texas i was like oh man this is kind of
the perfect time you know um
because i didn't know texas was what it
was man we went through midland and
lubbock yeah and um
and that's when we went through
albuquerque
and it's i mean it's
they got some real people out there like
just people hiding out out there
there are some people hiding out there
people hiding behind cactus you'll see a
lot of dudes and they'll just be walking
around like this it's like this is great
you've been hiding behind a cactus bro
west texas west texas is its own animal
man
yeah yeah it's just it's its own thing
it's almost like being on mars but with
ranch dressing kind of i always say it's
like corpus christi without the ocean
i've never been to corpus that's what it
reminds me yeah but i love western
school there i grew up in east texas um
and so southeast texas and so pine trees
like thick ass national forest stuff
like that yeah so west texas has always
kind of been like you said like mars to
me like there's no trees yeah there's no
bushes yeah not a lot of grass
and then people come out to the just
like where'd they all come i know dude
and dude we'll sell eight thousand
tickets there and i'm like what are
these people doing yeah but it's great
man i love west texas midland odessa
lubbock um we've played el paso we just
played amarillo this past weekend um
that's so cool man so i love it out
there but yeah it's amazing how big it
is how many people are out there but
yeah i thoroughly enjoyed it i just
couldn't believe it like we'd pull up at
a venue
and we'd look around in the parking lot
you couldn't see anything forever yeah
you're like where how where are they but
where's people going to come from
you know
but then people it's like you're going
to see like a mars rover pull up
10 thousand people get out i know yeah
like an express
it's like the the last like that into
all the way out to california there's
just not a lot
going on you know there's like vegas
plopped in the middle out there it's
like the oasis but i mean it's just like
a whole stretch just like still like the
wild west man there's just no telling
like if you want to like if you're
wanted yeah by the law and you love
hardcore drugs yeah you have like a
thousand mile stretch right there where
no one's gonna find you and you can get
great drugs yeah so that's true man you
right there you're really on the front
porch of great drugs coming up through
mexico and stuff that's beautiful
um
look i've been burnt out
for a while
i've had a lot of burnout i mean just
exhausted
you know my body's sweating
stomach growing hair falling out
teeth feeling uh gentle
a lot of burnout
i've been working too much not taking
enough time for myself
well life's overwhelming in many people
can be burned out without knowing it
betterhelp online therapy wants to
remind you to prioritize yourself
talking with someone can help you figure
out what's causing stress in your life
better help is customized online therapy
that offers video phone and even live
chat sessions if you want to do it
virtual or unvirtual on the phone on the
text you can text hey i need help let's
say i'll help you
our listeners get 10 off their first
month at betterhelp.com
t-h-e-o that's
dot com b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p-com
theo if you
think you need help you do
you or you might so investigate it
you know i've had this issue i was
subscribed to some company i think it
was umbrellas
unanimous or something some small group
um you know i got on there to get my
sister an umbrella she was getting wet
and they said well dang welcome to
umbrella's unanimous i didn't see on a
little box at checkout it said if you
want to get um
unlimited umbrellas
um they even said um limited play on
words for them
and so i did it next thing you know
she's getting umbrellas every month god
damn so many umbrellas and just
unbelievable you know she you know can't
even get a glass of water down her these
days
i'm telling you true bill
will help you it's the new app that
helps you identify and stop paying for
subscriptions you don't want need or
simply forgot about truebill they do it
that's right because companies make
subscriptions hard to cancel they trick
you they don't care about you they are
companies
just link your accounts and truebill
will cancel your unwanted subscriptions
in one tap
your true bill concierge is there when
you need them to cancel unwanted
subscriptions so you don't have to so
you can have help you need somebody to
call or do it for you they'll help
they have over 2 million users and have
helped save those users over 100 million
dollars that's fascinating
that's fascinating don't false for
subscription scams start canceling today
at truebill.com t-h-e-o
go right now
truebill.com theo it could save you
thousands a year
what about uh sometimes you used to sing
about drugs and some of your music and
stuff if you had any troubles with it or
whatever any point where you wanted to
kind of rein yourself back in or yeah
man i got um i i do not go near as hard
as i used to now i kind of i had to i
kind of had like a um
just a point where it was really through
covid like i hadn't been off the road
like that since i was 22. wow when i
started going on the road and uh
i mean sitting around with money in the
bank and nothing to do you know living
in downtown austin there's plenty to get
yourself into at the time and uh i just
went
a little too far and i had a couple
nights where i was like
you know
is this it kind of thing yeah and but
well you know
next day i was like i got i got i got to
get out and i'd been dating holly ray
for a while and i was like
you know it's uh i'm if i want to see 30
35 40
you know it's probably i just had i had
to get out dude i started you know it
all started partying and and all the fun
and games on the road and then
um you know when you when you take that
stuff back home with you and you're by
yourself
still doing those same things
that's when i was like
i think and i had so much to lose man
like my career started to really go well
you know i had pretty heart went number
one in platinum and i had a major record
deal and all this stuff and
and i was just going down the wrong road
and nobody knew like i didn't go to
rehab i didn't go tell anybody and tell
my parents i didn't tell anybody i told
my brother a little bit um but i just
kind of was like dude you're a grown
[ __ ] man you know and you got a lot
to lose and you got a lot on the line
um
and it's gonna be
a whole different ride
and probably a lot shorter ride if you
keep on the road you're on so i just
[ __ ] woke up one day and i was like
i'm done dude wow i'm out
good for you man that's powerful thank
you
that's powerful to have that ability to
have that wherewithal and then but also
to have that ability i think that's
where some people lack that
to say this is it you can get used to
anything that was really the way i
looked at it i was like dude you can you
can it's you get used to something so
quickly yeah you know anything about
like i'm sure you're talking about
earlier you've been on a private jet
yeah how easy is that to get used to
i just applied that same
mentality to the [ __ ] that i was doing
that i wasn't supposed to be doing and i
was like i can get used to living
without this yeah and it took a little
while
um but i was like i just i had to get
out dude i didn't want to i didn't want
to live i like i love being on the road
and waking up in the morning and feeling
good yeah like i look forward to the
show
i look forward to writing a record and
going to work and and trying hard that
was like something i didn't think was
cool for a long time yeah now i'm like
dude trying hard's dope as [ __ ] like
trying hard is a great
thing that i wish i would have
realized a long time ago i used to think
trying hard was like for losers yeah you
know this guy
[ __ ] put an effort in what a
ding-dong you know bro that's so
captivating because yeah when you're
like if you're kind of going through
school and stuff when you're in high
school and if like there's some dude
trying real hard you're like this dude
is a nerd yeah what a loser yes yeah but
then you kind of get around in your own
living your life you're like oh man if i
took what i net some of the natural
blessings that i've had
and applied some hard work to them yeah
damn babe it could be lights out man i
was living in that condo in downtown
austin
dry wall dog i'd be hanging drunk in my
lungs and there's a bar on top of that
building that's residents only that's
open from like four to two a.m every
night
looking over the city it's a super dope
place to live i'd never lived in the
city before i'd always live you know on
land or out in the country whatever and
um like inside the city like that i'd
never lived there and uh
and i wanted to do it and so it was a
lot of fun it really was it had a lot of
good times um but
it just and i think anything any good
advice i give to a young dude i'm like
set your time
pick your age like you're going to go as
hard as you can [ __ ] go you're going
to party until
28 or 35 or 25 whatever it is and then
that's your heart out and after that
it's time to try hard okay
so that's good advice man we had a
question coming here about suggestion
right here from a young fella let's get
to it real quick here
what up the uh what up parker
questions for parker so parker i'm
getting ready to move to nashville
as a songwriter and i was wondering what
advice would you have for
making those industry connections and
getting them better rooms and just what
advice would you give to somebody
getting ready to move to nashville to
try and do it
appreciate y'all ganked yeah hey baby
man i don't know
it's kind of a general question but he
seems sincere about it yeah i mean dude
it's it's uh
it kind of goes back to the trying hard
thing man i mean you can you don't have
to live here
you really don't george strait's the
king of country music he's never lived
in nashville never moved here
uh i moved here because i had to get out
of what i was just talking about in
austin like i had to go somewhere i had
to get out and
and that was my
like the only option for me at the time
and i can't wait to move back and buy a
ranch uh and move back to texas but
man
some other people are here there's a lot
of people trying to do it
but if you don't know what you're trying
to say
and you don't know
who you're trying to be or who you want
to be
then it's going to take a long time to
figure it out in this town um i think
you have to know like when i'm when i
started coming here randy rodgers from
the randy rogers band was managing me at
the time he's the one who told me to
come here he's like dude i think he
could be a superstar but you got to go
to this town and do it i didn't want to
go i didn't want to come here
and even when i started coming here i
would call him and i'd be like dude
i don't want to be here anymore like i'm
i don't want to come back and he's like
you need to like just trust me and it
was the greatest decision i ever made
shout out randy rodgers um
and uh and so
to that young man right there dude i
would just say know what you're coming
here to do before
you know what i mean like what kind of
what do you really want to be you just
want to be a songwriter then you need to
have some songs
that are absolutely as stout as a song
can be as well written as they can be so
when you come here you have a little
something to
to bargain you know you have a little
something to negotiate with it's kind of
like when i signed my record deal i was
already selling a bunch of tickets all
over right so i had all the the ball was
kind of in my court on the record i
didn't have to sign one i wanted to sign
one right so same thing as a songwriter
if you're coming here trying to get a
publishing deal
have a little something to publish going
already you know and be like hey i've
i've got these songs you know have a
little something in and you know you
don't just want to come in empty-handed
and you get signed into a bad deal
because you don't know any better and
you don't have anything to offer
um so that's a great point man yeah and
i think knowing what you have planned i
notice at the comedy store in los
angeles that's like a popular comedy
spot right there
and uh
and there'll be people that go there
they make uh the mecca out from wherever
you know to different cities or whatever
town they're from they get you know and
i'm gonna live here and then some of
them choose to just be somebody that
sits on the porch and drinks there every
every every other night you know it's
like
okay that's fine it's definitely a way
to be you know but it's like
are there you really living out what
your goal was you know some people yeah
they just they'll move to l.a and
they'll get invited all these parties
and stuff but then they're just up in
the hills doing coke every night and
it's like
you know five years go by it's like okay
well what were some of your goals and
aspirations did you really have any yeah
that's a you know i wish i had to set
some of those lines in my own life at
certain points same dude well dude i
just real i realized like as organically
as you can watch it unfold like the
people around me i was like
man nobody's like
no but everybody's coming over to my
house to party but nobody's trying to
make any money nobody's trying to build
a career nobody's trying to hustle
and it just took me like going to the
bottom of that hole
to be like
the [ __ ] dude trying hard and taking
care of your business and acting like a
grown man
that's cool [ __ ] yeah like it's not for
losers right it's really [ __ ] cool
yeah and i just it took me a little
longer to realize it then
i wish and do you think that some people
never get there some people never
realize that some people realize when
they're 60 some people are born like
that i guess like my sister she was born
like that she's just hustling out the
womb yeah um
oh yeah some little babies come out with
a watch yeah dude i like they're they're
just destined to hustle and everything's
success yeah you'll see a baby some of
them cut their own umbilical cord
absolutely dude like damn i uh um i
thought my sister made probably michael
was probably one of those people um
but yeah i don't know it's uh
i wish i would have realized that
younger but you're not you're not old no
you know you still got a lot of time and
your music is kind of like um you still
make music that almost fee
it's funny because your music makes me
feel
[Music]
your music makes me feel i feel young
when i listen to your music that's stuff
you know so i feel i don't feel like it
has because it only can have i feel like
music can really only have as much
history as you have
if somebody's really to believe it from
it yeah you're right what you know right
and this look i don't know anything
about music i'm just a person with two
ears
but
um
but yeah your music makes me feel like i
don't know i sing along to it you know i
feel like
my sister's it's not
you know like nowadays in country music
there's so much pop influence yeah like
a ton it's like basically rap in a way
pop music
and uh and like like wallen is like
that's the the greatest pop country i've
ever heard in my life dude yeah like he
it is the songs the production his voice
is so [ __ ] good dude but i like
that's just not like i i love that i
have that to listen to
i love that that's what he's doing but
like i'm so boring dude i just like
writing sad country love songs about
everything going terribly wrong yeah
and yeah i did and that's what this
whole podcast is about half the time
yeah we'll do that i just that's like
what i love and i'm and i'm like
it's kind of hard to
you know it's like so so much of the of
the genre of country music especially in
nashville is so pop influenced and
mine's just mine's not and so it's like
i i really struggle all the time i learn
i write songs i'm like
who the [ __ ] is he gonna listen to this
[ __ ] you know it's not making you bob
your head it's not making you want to
dance or drink beer like it's making you
want to go [ __ ] text old gal that you
swore
you would never talk to again
kind of thing big feelings yeah dude
that's my favorite song
it's my favorite favorite kind of song
so you know lamenting thinking about
things looking back you know and i think
what's interesting about it here's what
it is for such a guy for a guy your age
to have some of that perspective you
don't get a lot of that sometimes yeah
so i think that's what i think is really
enjoyable about it because it makes me
feel kind of young and old at the same
time that's dope um
because there's some perspective in it
you know it's a lot of looking back it's
a lot of like uh like you're driving
away from something i feel like a lot of
times yeah you know a lot of leaving
yeah a lot like this is the record i'm
writing right now like every song is
about going somewhere and leaving and
i'm like
who the [ __ ] wants to listen to this
[ __ ] you know hopefully a lot of people
but theo vaughn i'll listen baby dude i
thought your name for i listed you for a
long time before i realized that your
name was theo vaughn
i thought it was the ovon yeah do you
ever get that oh yeah yeah okay i'm not
the only one
okay yeah because i i was i would always
be like dude you guys know this guy the
ovon yeah and like [ __ ] you dom out
there yeah
it's two names bro from albuquerque yeah
albuquerque turkey dude
uh let's get into one more question that
came from a uh
from a fan for you so i just want to
make sure so that we got so you started
out music you started out in texas yeah
you
and where'd you get your first
instrument where'd you get into music i
just want our listeners to know
everything about you because someone
else may not know of you no 99 of them
don't um and they're probably going to
be like they're going to love you though
who's the dip [ __ ] well gold chains oh
you saved the day today thank you you
did i appreciate that for my first time
ever must be known um
blue ribbon for that man dude my i
played like orc like everybody in like
fifth and sixth grade was wanting to be
in the band and i was like [ __ ] that
dude no one's doing an orchestra i do
orchestra i just started playing the
violin
and then can you still play that [ __ ] no
and then
um my mom bought me a guitar um just
because she had my brother wanted one
for christmas and she didn't want me to
be all upset that i didn't get one right
so she bought me one and and my brother
would never [ __ ] teach me anything
like he would never he'd like i'd be
like yo way to trying to play that and
he'd be like dude [ __ ] out of my room
and uh and so i really just had to like
yeah you know i like learned on like the
internet once the internet very first
like there was a thing called cowboy
lyrics
on the internet back in the day and you
could look up like chords how to play
and i'll learn how to play chris knight
songs
and uh that's when i was in like seventh
grade
and i wrote this song called one man
mariachi band
and it was about like going to mexico
and running away and starting a one-man
mariachi band
and uh so that would end up in my my my
mom was like hey that's pretty good so i
like kept doing it you know and then i
wrote a song my freshman year high
school called permanent headphones it's
not on the internet or anything anymore
i think you can find it on soundcloud
and uh my brother was like dude
like he came home from college and and i
played that song for him permanent
headphones and he was like
he's like dude you're going to be the
next george strait and i was like
damn that's a lot of pressure yeah dude
i was like like
ease up on that dude you know uh
but it was him saying [ __ ] like that and
stealing that confidence in me that i
actually might be good at it
um and so i just i fell in love with it
dude i was like i mean you know all my
buddies when i was in junior high in
high school listened to
like at the time it was like
chamillionaire and
um like flo rida and yeah all these
rappers that were big in like the
mid-2000s yeah and i was listening to
chris knight and adam carroll and slade
cleaves and james at merchant and robert
earl o'keene and randy rodgers and pat
green and crosstainer ragweed and um i
mean just all these great songwriters i
was like obsessed with it and todd
snyder i was just completely obsessed
with it
and i had no friends that listened to
that so it was kind of like and then
once i got into high school and i was
like i was a real average athlete like i
wasn't going to play college ball
clearly and i was like hard huh no not
at all dude and i was like
because i would like realize when i was
like a sophomore in high school i was
like
i was like i'm not faster than anybody
but i can play guitar and sing better
than every one of those son of a [ __ ]
and so my junior year of high school i
was walking out of the workout and i
told my head coach i was like i'm gonna
quit football go play guitar and he's
like that's the biggest mistake of your
life
also if he's a texas football coach he
has to say that yeah it's the only line
he has like if you pull the string on
his back like have you seen daisy
confused yeah and you know pink and he
doesn't want to sign the contract he
doesn't want to play on the team he's a
quarterback he's real lazy okay
i was like and that's like one of my
favorite movies of all time and i was
just dead set on being
that guy
and all my buddies were like dude you're
such an idiot for quitting football what
are you doing and i was like yeah [ __ ]
that and now what are you doing
now every one of them's like
damn dude i saw you on television yeah
i'm like damn
y'all see about the limestone yeah let's
go you see me on theo vaughn
gang baby shout out my buddy jeff bean
if he's watching this man he was super
stoked i was coming on here today he's a
big fan was he yeah well thanks jeff bro
praise god bro praise god
yeah i'm trying to think of what else to
talk about man i think we got i think we
got a good dose of of you man i don't
want to keep myself super underwhelming
dude i always apologize when people come
up and ask for pictures and stuff i'm
like i wish i was cooler to meet i was
like i'm sorry i'm super underwhelming
being met is underwhelming though yeah
being met i feel like it's like you
can't get met yeah you can't like
compete with what you're capable of or
whatever your skill is it's like as a
human you falter to feel like
you know people be like yesterday i do
came between the airport bro i was like
it was plain delays and blah blah blah
blah like that he was like are you theo
von braun and i was like not today i'm
not yeah
i said [ __ ] not today dude the
airport the airport can be the worst
because usually like if you're on your
way it's like a thursday you're flying
somewhere to start the weekend yeah
you're like oh yeah [ __ ] out let's take
some pictures like good to see y'all too
but if it's on sunday yeah and you're
like a connecting flight home you know
and you just feel so shitty or so
hungover and you got people mobbing in
the airport it's like
[ __ ] this yeah you know but y'all i'm
always trying to be as sweet as i can be
oh totally be patient with them take the
pictures but i'm just always like dude
i'm sorry i wish i would like i just
write sad country songs yeah there's
nothing very impressive about it yeah
i'm talking next baby i'm just i'm
basically just a musical kleenex
you know
um
parker thanks so much man honestly bro
you really made my day man i mean i just
uh and i hate to you know make it about
me it was just a [ __ ] it was just hectic
yesterday and i was like how do i do
because i was like how do i get my
feelings and my mental back to a regular
level where i can just have a
conversation that's heavy [ __ ] dude
yesterday sounds like it was some heavy
[ __ ] so it was just like yeah it was
i've been through that with it with
someone in my family back home and uh
it's still it's he's still going through
it he's still
battling that every single day and uh
and so i've i mean i i get it dude 100
i've been down that road with him
well thanks man thanks for being
understanding no sweat dude yeah thanks
for carrying the show today bro yeah i
really did i'm just glad to be here dude
i'm a big fan i've watched it a lot i
still think the ray charles reverse
ghost joke
is one of the greatest jokes i've ever
heard i tell it all the time and uh i
heard that and i was like i want to go
on that show oh dude well that's awesome
man yeah i appreciate it bro yeah i
didn't know what it was gonna be like
man you really saved the day today so
thank you dude yeah thanks for coming
through uh parker mccollum guys if you
guys haven't heard him check out his
music man if you like if if you're
listening to this podcast
then a lot of his music is going to fit
right uh it's going to fit right inside
of your heart man all one point
three to five liters baby oh all three
leaders baby the baby pool yeah gang
baby
you